the video was filmed and distributed by
the russian state media ukrainian
soldiers apparently surrendering in
mariopol
sky news has located it to an area of
the city and it looks like a genuine
surrender but we cannot know for sure
the russians though would like the world
to believe that it represents the
beginning of the end for the ukrainian
military in this key port in the far
east
in the area of the steel plants as a
result of successful offensive actions
by the russian troops and militia units
of the donetsk people's republic
ukrainian servicemen of the 36th marine
brigade voluntarily laid down their arms
and surrendered
the russians will also use this as
evidence that they are respecting the
lives of their enemy
but listen to the ukrainian mayor of
mariopol the story he tells is grim
the fact that 90 of infrastructure has
been raised by the russian federation
that the hospitals were bombed the bomb
shelters were bombed that the innocent
civilians were killed in mario
21 000 plus
is the number of fatalities in mario
again with the city almost blocked off
this cannot be verified but from the
satellite imagery it looks like the
urban wastelands the russians left
behind in aleppo syria and grozny
chechnya
the mayor insists that the ukrainian
forces will continue to fight
they are vastly outnumbered but they are
holding out at the city of madrupal
remains a ukrainian city
but for how much longer these are the
first images inside the theatre taken on
a trip organized by the russians of
selected city locations it was bombed
nearly a month ago hundreds were
sheltering inside the confirmed number
known to have died is still not clear
but it's the russians who now hold
what's left of it
on the claim of chemical weapons being
used here there is still no clarity
and the ukrainian president said today
that phosphorus bombs were used by the
russians he didn't mention chemical
weapons but did again call for more arms
the images of butcher and mariupol have
demonstrated real russian's intentions
to the whole world
it could only be stopped by force of
arms it must be done now
ukraine needs to have on supplies
we need heavy artillery armed vehicles
air defense systems and combat aircraft
with the russians now fully withdrawn
from areas around kiev moscow's new
general in charge a syria and chechnya
veteran is consolidating the command and
the troop numbers here in the far east
the final battle for mariopol looks
imminent
mark stone sky news in eastern ukraine